three senior politicians now each in the
race for Downing Street
appointed Chancellor just days ago as
his colleagues were resigning Nadeem
zahawi is promising tax cuts and a boost
to defense spending the Iraqi Refugee
turned businessmen clearly appealing to
MP's eager for a different approach to
the economy
health committee chair Jeremy Hunt lost
out to Boris Johnson in the 2019 contest
one of the most experienced contenders
the former entrepreneur says he wants to
win back trust and grow the economy
transport secretary Grant shaps has been
a loyal Ally of the current prime
minister
he's pitching himself as a traditional
conservative who won't Chase headlines
but a cabinet minister not standing for
Downing Street is one time bookie's
favorite Ben Wallace the defense
secretary and former Soldier had been
speaking to his family about running he
now says he wants to focus on his
current job popular with conservative
members across the country this
high-profile exit will be some relief to
other contenders Ben Wallace was top he
came out in any contest against any
Comer so the whole thing really is
thrown pretty wide open on our accounts
we've listed 19 people who at one time
or another have expressed an interest
have said they're going to Ronald said
they may run and that seems rather a lot
to me Kenny badanok is a less well-known
entrant to announcing her candidacy the
community's minister promised lower
taxes but tight spending discipline as
well as a commitment to free speech they
could be around a dozen people who
eventually stand in what is a wide open
race to succeed Boris Johnson here but
even with only a handful already
declared we're already starting to see
some important ideological differences
opening up have you got what it takes to
BPM former Chancellor Rishi sunak has
had the most endorsements so far with
potentially the backing of former Prime
Minister David Cameron for others in the
party though his time in the treasury is
a turn off because of his record as
Chancellor he now has to double down on
the high tax position that he's taken
the big question is whether taxation at
this level is doing more harm than good
and I'm afraid I I think that it is so
although I've got admiration for Rishi
and he's often said all the right things
he's now doubling down on on a very
difficult position that I think is quite
harmful
but sunak supporters say he'll be the
grown-up in the room
he's a tax cutter and so am I but you've
got to tax to take out the tax
responsively because otherwise you're
gonna have to take really massive
reductions in public spending probably
more than we can bear at the moment or
borrow more and more and that's actually
just shoving the taxation burden onto
the Next Generation
locked in meetings with advisers at a
London home foreign secretary Liz truss
is also likely to show her hand in the
coming Days Seven contenders now running
with more to come ample choice for Tory
MPS varying paths ahead for the
government and the country